son camion ranger aménagé adeline jean
françois est prête à recevoir ses
premiers clients
vous allez le parc on a été chercher
tout à l'heure la tipica un chasse neige
vous avez dû beaucoup les fourrages la
perte de la tramblais j'ai aussi la
viande
huit fromages légumes fruits ou encore
biscuits dans cette épicerie installé
sur quatre roues l'ensemble de la
production et yvelinoise un pari de
proximité porté par cet ancien employé
de banque pour qui vendre ses produits
c'est avant tout défendre une manière de
consommer c'est vrai qu'en grande
surface au final on a tout ce qui est
tout ce qu on a tout au long de l'année
quad et thomas toute l'année tout ça il
faut en fait apprendre aux gens à vivre
avec les saisons est vraiment avec les
produits qui sont produits juste à côté
quelquefois à la tomate en plein hiver
on a ras-le-bol quoi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment respectée aussi cette
saisonnalité parce qu'on respecte
également la nature est dédiée
initialement à la vente à domicile
adeline a dû s'adapter pour répondre à
une demande toujours en hausse
la vente ambulante est devenu un service
apprécié des habitants des villages et
bourgs yvelinois est indispensable
partant de coronavirus j'aime bien parce
que c'est laid
du point et puis
et puis 20
c'est petit c'est sympa et puis voilà
ces compliments quand il bat wil risque
arrange aller faire mes courses et
les grands magasins et maintenant je ne
vais ça fait une quinzaine de jours
qu'on est des confiné moi je ne se
ressent pas en fait la baisse pour
l'instant où l'éventuel départ de
certains clients qui retournent à leurs
anciennes habitudes satisfaire les
clients mais aussi travailler avec les
producteurs du coin ils sont désormais
une trentaine à fournir adeline en
aliments chez comme l'un de ses premiers
partenaires elle vient chercher
notamment de belles fraises de saison
c'est vraiment pour défendre enfin créer
de la dynamique dans la région tout ça
permet de te faire découvrir nos
produits aussi indirectement c'est sur
cs c'est une vitrine on a une vitrine
chez devrions payer
fort de son succès l'épicerie mais
produit des yvelines a pu embaucher son
premier employé il y a quelques semaines
si les bonnes habitudes prises pendant
le confinement se confirme l'offre
locale et de proximité 100% yvelinoise
pourrait encore s'élargir